hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of modeling the Masters
I believe that the fastest and most
effective way to grow your business is
to model the strategies of people who've
already done what you're trying to do so
today we're going to look at how mother
of two was forced to start her own
business after her husband left her to
travel across America having no formal
training her survival instinct kicked in
and she was able to go from nothing to
building one of the most trusted brands
in the world this is a story of body
shop founder Anita Roddick and the top
three lessons that you can learn from
her success Anita Roddick was a British
businesswoman human rights activist an
environmental campaigner that's known as
the founder of the body shop a cosmetics
company producing and retailing beauty
products that shaped ethical consumerism
she was born into a hard-working
immigrant family and her mother ran a
successful cafe which kept the young
Roddick occupied for most of her
childhood in addition to a strong work
ethic her mother also taught her the
concept of recycling and how valuable
could be for businesses after graduating
school she took a trip around the world
and eventually wound up in Johannesburg
South Africa where she disobeyed the
laws of apartheid by tending the jazz
club on Black Knight and was sent back
to England upon arriving back home she
might Gordon Roddick and felt you had an
instant bond with him the two married
and opened up a restaurant and hotel
together after three years of running
the two businesses Gordon decided that
he wanted to fulfill his lifelong dream
of riding the horse from Buenos Aires
Argentina to New York City they sold the
restaurant business and Anita stayed
home with their two children while
Gordon was away on his adventure she
decided to create her own cosmetic store
that would sell natural and
environmentally conscious products she
started off selling 15 cosmetics
products that she made in her garage and
packaged in recycled bottles to reduce
the cost she soon opened a second
location and by the time her husband had
returned from his trip but were already
asking about franchising rights
by 2004 the body shop had almost two
thousand stores and served over 77
million customers around the world it
was also considered one of the most
trusted brands in the world a March
seventeenth 2006 L'Oreal bought the body
shop for 973 million dollars with the
sale Robert became more involved in
charity work and began giving away her
money to cause as she believed it when
she died in 2007 she left her estate to
charities action item number one get
past survival we all have big dreams
what we want ourselves and our companies
to become but in order to make those
dreams a reality you need to first get
past a survival point with your business
you need to know that your company will
be able to give you enough money to put
food on the table and pay your bills
this is one of the most important first
steps you need to accomplish as you
start your business once you have enough
money coming in you can focus on
shooting for your bigger goals when
Anita Roddick first started the body
shop it wasn't because she wanted to
create social environmental change with
her husband gone she had to find a way
to make money to support herself and her
two children the main reason behind
opening the body shop was so that her
family could survive as an example she
couldn't afford more than 700 empty
bottles so she took the unusual step of
offering five sizes of every product
even though she had very few products
initially when you entered her 370
square foot store it would give the
illusion she carried over a hundred and
twenty products according to erotic
nobody was stupid enough to offer five
sizes of long product it simply didn't
make sense we turned it around into a
survivors option customers pick up the
size they want and come back every week
for a refill recycling had nothing to do
with being environmentally conscious at
that point my goal was livelihood at the
forefront of my mind the time there was
really only one thought survival I
started the body shop in 1976 simply to
create a livelihood for myself and my
two dollars while my husband Gordon was
trucking across the Americas I had no
training or experience and my own only
business acumen was Gordon's advice to
take sales of 300 pounds a week
nobody talks of entrepreneurship as
survival but that's exactly what it is
and what nurtures creative thinking
action item number two use your business
to do good the most successful
businesses seem to be the ones who don't
just focus on making money but instead
try to be a force for good in their
industry entrepreneurs are also now
leading the way to help others beyond
their customers they're using their
companies to support the communities
around them and give back not just
because they can but because it also
makes good business sense Anita Roddick
social and ecological conscience
initially stem from a lack of money she
had the recycle bottles because she
couldn't afford to buy new ones the
store was painted green because she
wanted to hide the damp stains on the
walls however as the body shop grew to
become a powerful player in the
cosmetics business Roderick began to use
her newfound influence to try to have a
positive impact on the world around her
according erotic I hate the beauty
business it's a monster industry selling
unattainable dreams that lies it cheats
it exploits women I want to work for a
company that contributes to and is part
of the community I want something not
just to invest in I want something to
believe in if I can't do something for
the public good what the hell am i doing
action item number 3 learn by doing it's
hard to learn how to be an entrepreneur
from a book you can read to get inspired
or to get new ideas but nothing is
really going to happen until you start
to apply those ideas into your business
you can use books and courses to
supplement your knowledge and give you
the guidance but you have to actually
apply what you're learning if you really
want to understand and retain the
information Anita Roddick never learned
about being an entrepreneur at school
instead she learned from her mother who
she saw worked tirelessly to make her
cafe successful while other cafes kept
regular nine-to-five hours her mother
opened the dawn for the local fishermen
and didn't close until the last customer
had left Roddick had never read a book
on economic theory in her life and while
her naysayers believe this would be her
downfall Roddick saw it as one of her
competitive advantages accorded neurotic
I often get asked to talk about
entrepreneurship even by hollowed
institutions like Harvard and Stanford
but I'm not at all convinced
it's a subject you can teach how do you
teach obsession because more often than
not it's obsession that drives an
entrepreneurs vision why would you march
a different drum beat if you are
instinctively part of the crowd they
will not teach you the most crucial
thing of all how to be an entrepreneur
that might also SAP what entrepreneurial
flair you have as they force you into a
template called an MBA if I learned more
about business ahead of time I would
have she'd been shaped into believing
that it was only about finances and
quality management by not knowing any of
that I had an amazing freedom potential
entrepreneurs are outsiders they're
people who imagine things as they might
be not as they are and have the drive to
change the world around them those are
skills that business schools do not
teach so remember get past survival use
your business to do good and learn by
doing to finish up this video I wanted
to share one of my favorite true stories
about Anita Roddick and some of her best
quotes Anita Roddick first location was
next to a funeral parlor given a whole
new meaning to the body shop name when
she began franchising she had little
experience and decided not to charge
startup or royalty fees however before
she would accept franchisees they would
have to interview with her product ass
off the wall questions like what is your
favorite flower and how would you like
to die to get to know her candidates on
a more personal level
thank you for joining me for another
dish at modeling the Masters if you like
the video and you want to see more
please give it a thumbs up below I'd
also love to hear your thoughts if you
want to leave a comment under the video
and stay tuned for the next episode
you